und dann so um 18 30 sitze und meinem
schreibtisch geht es auf einmal los
dickel kartoffelsalat service kis und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
heute spielen wir crossover games ist es
bin ich jetzt wirklich spectator so
jetzt wir wirklich in der runde leute
und ich darf euch heute zwei geschichten
zu einem kanal erzählen und eine wie
love story mode zu kommen
aber lasst uns erstmal loslegen mit den
geschichten zu meinem kanal
es gibt ja so ein ding leute also so ein
ding auf youtube wisst ihr was ich meine
also das kommt öfters mal vor introns
vor videos und das nennt sich ich hab es
kann eben schon verraten sich
verplappert es nennt sich intro leute
und ich hatte ja lange lange lange zeit
auf einem kanal kein intro also wirklich
lange nicht mit bestimmtheit sagen wie
lange aber es waren viele jahre auf
jeden fall vielleicht sogar jahrzehnt so
berlin holen
also realistisch gesagt was kein
jahrzehnt aber vielleicht ein halbes
jahr mehr oder weniger ein jahrzehnt
sagen wir mal so irgendwann ist halt
auch mal die zeit gekommen wo man mal
wieder neues intro brauch leute und ich
kann euch berichten
jemand hat sich meine erbarmt und ich
habe ein neues intro ich habe es auch
schon ein paar leuten gezeigt die fans
soweit menschen nicht gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend richtig cool bis auf nico der
hat irgendwie eigenen ideen
ich mag es auch richtig weil es ein song
ist den ich sehr sehr gerne höre zu dem
dieses intro gemacht wurde und ich hab
mich da sehr von meinen musikalischen
wünschen leiten lassen habe quasi dem
intro designer nur gesagt ich möchte
diese art von intro und ich möchte
diesen titel um jeden preis also nach
der tüte posten ich auf gar keinen fall
es geht nicht genauso nicht anders gehen
ja und dann irgendwie hat das noch
hinbekommen
ich hasse nichts mehr als 72 gegner
eingeklemmt sein das schlimmste selbst
bist einfach an fahrerisch folgte mir
okay ich zuerst mal märz tatsächlich
hinbekommen und er hat so hinbekommen
dass es mir sogar gefällt und das will
was heißen denn sollte es haben schon
einige intro designer
seitdem versucht es ich soll jetzt nicht
überheblich klingen aber es hat mir
beiden eigentlich allen nicht gefallen
weil ich kein neues intro habe bis dahin
hatte ich kein neues intro also als
macht haben und jetzt mein neuer
interessanter ich werde jetzt noch nicht
faul an wert ist weil sonst könnte man
nachschauen und gucken da vielleicht
schon eine kleine kostprobe von dem
intro online deswegen werde ich erstmal
nicht sagen präsentierte er ein reines
thc reingehen dass mein statement nicht
sagt noch nicht was es ist aber ich kann
euch sagen was als kommt eigentlich
wollte ich euch das heute schon in den
heutigen video zeigen kann mal so viel
so viele background infos geben aber es
gab einfach das problem dass mein
designer irgendwie bis sehr früh
schlafen geht braunau
jetzt geht er dauernd ja okay der andere
ist reina mir das mal ein pfeil
vielleicht auch zwei vielleicht auch
drei vielleicht auch vier
ich kann nur soviel sagen alter der
postbank wird riehl und jetzt wirst du
mich auch postpaid oder wird es ja jetzt
hab ich ihn in der ecke und hunde grund
sehr und wir springen in runde zwei
grund nummer zwei ich war da stehen
geblieben dass man in two designer früh
schlafen geht dazu müssen zwei dinge
wissen und zwar habe ich zwei laptops
einen privaten laptop der liegt bei mir
ne buddel rum und einen arbeits- laptop
den habe ich von der firma bekommen und
der ist im büro und heute mittag habe
ich meinem interessanter geschrieben
habe sagt jo kannst du mir mal das intro
schicken in der fertigen formblatts
einfach überlebt diesen sturz warum hat
es überlebt okay jetzt tag gestorben
bitte und er malte jakschik ich dazu und
so habe ich das bekommen und ich muss
gut gelaufen vor dem weg damit ich das
racket er ist damit die triacon bitte
greift er nicht an indem hinten greift
mich auch an herr 27 17 uhr geschickt
und ich dachte so uncool ist auf das
intro damals hat mein video drüber saß
dann heute abend an einem desktop pc den
habe ich auch das quasi mein dritter
pc.de okay ist uns was auf zeigt sich
den leuten dann im video alles
entspannter überlege ich mir ja okay du
hast du das intro eigentlich wenn es
jetzt gleich rein schneiden muss und
dann ist mir eingefallen
ich habe das auf dem arbeits laptop und
der arbeits laptop steht noch im büro
also hab ich es nicht und dann schreibe
ich beim intro designern so haye hat
sich das intro schicken
ich habe jetzt meinen laptop und skype
kann er wie die datenübertragung nicht
nochmal starten für den an
laptop und seine antwort war er hat
einfach nicht geantwortet
um halb elf also style cave schreibt man
die kommentare des halb elf zu viel
verlangt ist es zu spät schon also halb
elf ist für mich also gar so langsam
kann man anfangen aufzunehmen so
ungefähr also 23 stunden vorm
schlafengehen und das obwohl ich ein
geregelter tagesablauf habe ich gehe
jeden tag arbeiten so trotzdem halb elf
zu meiner verwunderung war er dann nicht
mehr wach und deswegen dass die
quintessenz der ganzen geschichte kann
ich euch heute in diesem video obwohl
ich möchte einfach noch nicht das ende
zeigen das ist eigentlich richtig nervig
für mich weil ich sehr gerne zeigen
möchte aber ich kann nicht weil ich
nicht dran kommen momentan ich habe nur
so eine vorläufige version mit einem
komischen karierten hintergrund also ist
einfach nicht das original ich möchte
euch wenn ich euch zeige dann richtig
zeigen nicht so eine halbgare version wo
dann die vorfreude schon weg ist wenn
man zu einem video sieht denkt man sich
so ja ok kennt ja schon
nee ich möchte ich wenn ich zeige
richtig zeigen dann direkt in einem
video nach dem break
vom richtigen video so möchte ich gerne
ab und da sind wieder zwei wärs der
costa brava schon okay alles lacht ihr
habt gerade ein bisschen so team gezeigt
auch die leute ihr habt das bessere
equipment ihr müssten nicht team
zusammenkommt team vom team junger gott
okay wobei ich dann stehen geblieben ich
laufe jetzt aber weg die heutige partie
schaut euch das an
wir können sicherlich nochmal anschauen
ich darf darüber macht ihr ach komm halt
deine nicht mach dir du hast mit dem
anderen geteilt es ist verboten
ob bitte fall einfach dieses loch du
hast es dir wirklich redlich verdient
also das war die erste geschichte das
intro die zweite geschichte die ich noch
erzählen möchte bekomme ich mehr von so
lang weiter keinen bock mehr hat gib mir
dein bogen
ich werde dich loben
ich sage einfach alle zufrieden sein so
die zweite geschichte erzählen wollte
ist das format mit dem hacker also die
hacker ich solche den namensschutz
dollar
nein doch doch ich wollte soll ich kann
mich schon mal den namen sagen das kann
man machen
jojo ich werde ihn einfach so lange
abfahrten bis dagegen die anderen camp
ganz easy aber ich habe einfach keine
kidman 41 punkte etwa vergessen oder bis
ein leichtsinnsfehler macht und ich ihn
in die lage boxen kann es wird hacker
reißen das neue format und das wird
richtig cool ich freue mich da extrem
junge ich weiß dass der andere dann bist
du mit dem tsb ist trotzdem
gegeneinander kämpfen alter du kleiner
so viel kann ich euch schon mal zu dem
neuen projekt sei aber ich möchte auch
dazu sagen dass ich mir diesmal so viel
zeit lassen oder nehmen werde bis das
projekt wirklich ausgereift ist und
nicht den eindruck habe dass ich soweit
ist dass ich jetzt vergessen möchte ich
möchte das nicht zu früh raus hauen denn
ich habe den eindruck dass ich in meiner
youtube karriere geschichte whatever
schon ein zwei mal ein projekt zu früh
sie liest ab als es noch nicht ganz
wirklich ausgereift und das ist halt
irgendwie menschlich gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend weil dann hat man irgendwie
eine gute idee mal haut zu früh raus
manche von euch kennt vielleicht die
selbst youtube machen das ist gerade
sehen und die leute sagen ich soll ja
eigentlich eine gute idee aber die
umsetzung ist irgendwie ich so klein
deswegen will ich warten bis ich
wirklich gute ideen für die umsetzung
hat uns auch nicht umsetzen kann
dass die zweite geschichte und momentan
habe ich einfach keine zeit dafür mich
da wirklich hin zu setzen das geht nur
am wochenende unter der woche bin ich
halt von morgens bis abends 19 20 uhr
bei der arbeit
danach kommen irgendwelche andere
termine zum beispiel ja verliert sich
sagen aber ein anderer termin die auch
wichtig sind
und nein nicht nutzen sondern egal leute
ist selber wichtige termine so da muss
man zum beispiel beim einkauf oder
klamotten vielleicht diesen gegner hier
die junge das gibt's doch nicht das
gibt's doch nicht da hab ich dich
überrascht das gibt es doch nicht da hab
ich dich doch wirklich überrascht hat
man ja so sein equipment
und ich anziehen wegen der ess regel
schiebt aber ja unter der woche habe ich
einfach keine zeit dafür
dann komme ich habe zwanzig nach hause
will erst mal eine stunde weil es auch
mal irgendwann muss auch mal chillen
bisschen runterkommen und dann fange ich
an aufzunehmen und zu schneiden für
nächsten tag fand mitzumachen und am
ende kriege ich doch immer zu wenig
schlaf der zwei live aber hey es macht
auch bock muss man sagen
aber fakt ist unter der woche ist es
einfach ganz ganz schwer datei zu
bekommen klappt in der regel nicht und
deswegen werde ich mich am wochenende
erst hinsetzen können weil irgendein
wochenende und deswegen dauert aussage
am letzten wochenende hatte ich die zeit
nicht weil war erstes wochen eine
berliner firma wissen draußen so und da
habe ich mir die zeit auch nicht
genommen ganz ehrlich jetzt mitnehmen
können aber hat einfach nicht gepasst
dieses wochenende könnte es ein bisschen
besser passen bin zwar bei meiner
familie oft durch die wand durch ich
glaub's nicht richtiger thriller
die dauert alter mann ein feiner du bist
als ob er dem endauswahl jung ist sollte
diese mehr auszuweichen
vielleicht kommt zeit kommt darin gehe
da reingehen
das ist die zweite geschichte zu meinem
kanal dass die usa was da vorne ist dass
der nein
doch das ist da kam schon lady diana
bernadotte ja okay ist zwar schön aber
okay deathmatch kabarett genau kämpfer
gegen der inhalt
ok dann wunderbar das kann schön die
dritte sache ist eine love story aus dem
büro und zwar heute mittag einfach so
richtig witzig auch durch büro mir fällt
auf dass an einer ecke einfach so keine
ahnung wie fans so 99 fässer einfach
aufeinander getürmt stehen zu so einer
pyramide patienten nicht to be one leute
jetzt besser equipment
was man nicht machen kann jedoch zu
erzählen die geschichte die schon aber
diese fest ich denke mir überhaupt und
dann so um 18 30 sitze in meinem
schreibtisch geht auf einmal los dicke
tüte kartoffelsalat ich vielleicht ein
bisschen arbeiten und auf einmal stürmer
allen anderen raum und mache einfach das
bier auf damit aber so vollkommen
rennende war dafür mag ich auch meinen
job einfach dass diese aktion so das
macht mir einfach so oft oder auf den
elektrischen longo durch bürokosten sich
aber so was dann
dann habe ich einfach angefangen aus
diesen fässern zu trinken sag ich mal
nicht zu saufen oktoberfest geht auch im
beruf das was im heutigen video haut
rein macht es gut und nur von lady okay
du gehst geh doch mal mit dem ball kommt
zu machen und auch jetzt wieder eklige
to be born situation erkundigt schuss
die man ich habe eigentlich auch einen
geregelten tagesablauf so ist es ja
nicht wie so was liebe die einfach so
menschen die altersrente komplett
renovierte combo auspacken sculfor
nichts von ihm
leute ich hab ich wollte einfach gerade
geschickt und dann kommt ein top einfach
aus dem himmel als alter was ist los mit
dir
glaubt ihr ab falls man die eigentlich
noch nicht hätten geleast werden sollen
in varel alter ich für euch ich kenne
wirklich eine anfall es ist so verrückt
wie viele aufnahmen ich schon hier
verbraucht